[Applause]
off speed pitch laced in the left center
field outman on the Run misjudged it and
it pops out of his glove and here's
martes printing for second and diving
in that distinctive stretch style of
Kershaw ball hit through the middle
Marte around third he's going to score
and the Diamondbacks who had to come
from behind in both games in Milwaukee
jump in front here at Dodger
Stadium line to left to base hit
Carol stops at
second his 14th pitch of this inning is
driven to deep left back way back and
off the wall one run is home as Carol
Sprints for the plate and they'll have
second and third with a two- nothing
lead and Kershaw is yet to retire a
hitter highfly ball to deep left field
forget about it it's gone
a disastrous start for Clayton
Kershaw Moreno hit only seven during the
regular season put a major charge into
that
[Applause]
one I think Dbacks and every deback who
is faced Kershaw has delivered a hit and
they ball been hit hard always tries to
get that slider underneath the hands of
the righty to jam them this ball never
made it there stayed right in the middle
of the plate and Mareno with a loud
answer and Longoria slams one toward the
Gap in left center field and outman
Dives but can't get it it will go to the
wall Thomas on his way to Third and
being waved home it's a double for
Longoria the peg to the plate is late
and it's 6 nothing Diamondbacks I'm out
for seamer supposed to be a away and
down it's up and middle to the birthday
boy 38-year-old Evan
Loria Roberts comes to get
Kershaw he's had a rough time before in
the postseason this has to be the worst
of all the those outings